autre nouveauté l'arrivée du pass
sanitaires il sera exigé pour participer
à de grands rassemblements réunissant
plus de 1000 personnes les festivals et
événements sportifs ainsi que pour
voyager
alors quelles sont les nouvelles
conditions pour partir à l'étranger les
précisions avec guy marosi la théorie
elle est relativement simple l'exécutif
a classé les pays selon trois couleurs
et les conditions de voyage diffèrent en
fonction de la couleur du pays concernés
à commencer par les pays envers jugés
les plus sûrs c'est-à-dire ceux où l'on
considère qu'il n'y a pas de circulation
active du virus
il s'agit de l'espace européen de la
nouvelle-zélande de l'australie du japon
de la corée du sud du liban et d'israël
viennent ensuite les pays en orange
c'est à dire ceux où il y à une
circulation active du virus mais dans
des proportions maîtrisé
c'est le cas de la plupart des pays à
travers la planète on peut noter la
russie la chine les etats unis le
royaume uni ou encore la quasi totalité
des états africains viennent enfin les
pays classé en rouge dans cela
le virus circule activement et l'on a
noté la diffusion deux variants
préoccupant il s'agit principalement du
sous continent indien de l'afrique du
sud de la turquie et de la plupart des
états sud américains
alors vous l'aurez deviné les règles
sanitaires les conditions de voyage
deviennent de plus en plus strictes en
allant du vert au rouge par exemple se
rendre au liban ne requiert aucun motif
particulier et tout voyageur arrivant de
ce pays devront présenter un test
négatif uniquement s'ils ne sont pas
vaccinés en revanche tout voyage
d'agrément en inde est encore impossible
et toute personne arrivant de ce pays
devra se soumettre à un test anti
génique et respecter une quarantaine
stricte 2 10 jours à son arrivée dans
l'hexagone alors ça c'est pour la
théorie la pratique est toujours un peu
plus compliqué
tout simplement parce qu'il s'agit là de
règles sanitaires françaises et sans
réciprocité
par exemple il est possible en théorie
de se rendre dans l'archipel nippon
classées en vert mais le japon lui ne
délivre toujours pas de visa aux
ressortissants français
il est également impossible de se rendre
en australie car le pays maintient ses
frontières fermées et ce jusqu'au 17
juin